-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight
and, now, we are going
to get to the news.
President Biden is set on Monday
to sign the bipartisan
infrastructure bill into law,
provided they can get
Joe Manchin off of it.
[ Laughter ]
After New Hampshire
Governor Chris Sununu
announced this week that he will
not run next year for Senate,
Minority Leader Mitch McConnell
is reportedly upset
that Sununu did not give him
advance notice
or -- hear me out --
that's just how he looks.
[ Laughter ]
That photo was taken
at Six Flags.
[ Laughter ]
During their virtual summit
next week,
Chinese, President Xi Jinping
is reportedly expected
to invite President Biden to the
2022 Beijing Winter Olympics,
but, for his part,
Biden says he'll only go
if he qualifies.
[ Laughter ]
According a new poll,
76% of Americans said
that Facebook
makes society worse.
Said Zuckerberg, "Right,
but what do you think of Meta?"
[ Laughter ]
Apple CEO Tim Cook said,
in an interview this week,
that he's worried
about the amount of time
people spend "scrolling
mindlessly" on their devices,
which is kind of like hearing
that your weed dealer
is worried you sleep too much.
[ Laughter ]
The Canadian fast-food chain
Tim Hortons announced
a collaboration
with pop star Justin Bieber
to launch three new flavors
of doughnut holes.
When they first come out,
they'll be cute,
but then, they'll become
really annoying.
[ Laughter ]
Then, all of a sudden,
you'll be like, "Wait a minute.
Are these doughnut holes
actually good?"
[ Laughter ]
Before realizing you are
way too old to be enjoying them.
[ Laughter ]
A 105-year-old runner,
Julia "Hurricane" Hawkins,
recently set a world record
in the 100-meter dash
for her age group.
The new record is eight meters.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm totally fine
with your reaction.
[ Laughter ]
According to new reports,
reality star Kim Kardashian's
shapewear brand SKIMS'
collaboration
with the luxury
fashion brand Fendi
sold out in just one minute,
continuing the Kardashian
family trend
of immediately selling out.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, today is
actor Leonardo DiCaprio's
47th birthday
and, when he blew out
the candles,
he was still Leonardo DiCaprio.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, I got my wish!"
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.